je demande je vais demander à pascal
montredon maintenant résident la
conférencière confédération nationale
des buralistes
merci pierre bonjour à toutes et à tous
juste pour planter le décor du buraliste
avant tout dans le gard très proche de
la lozère une région que je connais très
bien pierre tu le sais et le réseau en
quelques chiffres c'est 25 mines
buralistes dont 44 % exercent en zone
rurale dans des communes de moins de
3500 habitants depuis 2012 est à peu
près trois mille petites entreprises qui
ont disparu dans le silence le plus
total des pouvoirs publics comme si
demain on n'existe plus le problème du
tabagisme sera résolu je suis pas en
train de faire l'apologie du tabagisme
loin de là nous avons toujours été
d'accord avec d'autres ministères de la
santé pour accompagner la baisse du
tabagisme mais lorsqu'on met en
opposition commerce qui va un produit
légal par rapport à une idéologie
ça ne peut pas fonctionner je ferme la
parenthèse est ce que j'ai envie de dire
puisque je suis là depuis ce matin très
tôt
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de similitudes
avec les agriculteurs
parce que comme vous nous ne supportons
pas que la france sur ce transpose
toujours plus les lois qui sont faites
au niveau européen la dernière en date
c'est le paquet neutre où la france va
l'imposer aux buralistes français aux
consommateurs français alors que le
reste de l'europe ne va pas le mettre en
place
on augmente la concurrence que vous
connaissez vous dans le monde de
l'agriculture
c'est un véritable scandale et puis
allons encore plus loin
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que lorsque
nous sommes indépendants que ce soit
médecin que ce soit paysans qu'ils
soient commerçants ou artisans
si mal vu on n'aime pas une société où
les gens ont envie d'entreprendre
pourquoi je ne comprends pas je ne
comprends pas cette position idéologique
encore une fois où du moment où on se
met à son compte
c'est malsain c'est parce que vous
gagnez trop d'argent mais quel mal y at
il de bien vouloir gagner sa vie mais
dans tout ça pour en revenir aux zones
rurales
il faut comprendre écouter ce que disent
les clients et nous avons encore la
chance en zone rurale en milieu péri
urbain ou dans les grandes villes et
dans certains quartiers difficiles
d'avoir toujours 10 millions de clients
qui pousse une porte je vous rassure pas
que pour consommer du tabac mais pour le
jeu pour la presse
pour ce lien de convivialité qui que
chacun d'entre nous a le droit de
retrouver et ce lien de convivialité est
en train de disparaître en zone rurale
elle est là aussi cette réalité parce
que lorsqu'on a fini une journée de
labeur dans les champs mais se retrouver
à la terrasse d'un café pour refaire le
monde pouvoir pour raconter ce qui va ou
ce qui ne va pas et bien tout cela est
en train de disparaître et j'accuse le
gouvernement actuel de ne pas se rendre
compte de ce qui est en train de se
passer
et pour en revenir au réseau des
buralistes nous pensons que nous avons
notre place toute entière dans le
paysage nous savons très bien que le
tabagisme doit continuer à baisser mais
nous sommes force de proposition auprès
des pouvoirs publics pour apporter de
nouveaux services qu'une municipalité
est un département une région que l'état
lui-même à travers ses différentes
administrations pourraient nous délégués
nous sommes preneurs parce que nous
sommes des commerçants
nous sommes également des préposés
d'administration il y avait cette double
casquette
je pense qu' il est temps de réfléchir
aussi tous ensemble pouvoir de quelle
façon on peut améliorer le quotidien
améliorer le quotidien des zones rurales
ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est que on
peut imaginer un certain service
universel qui passerait par la vente
obligatoire de timbres postaux de
services administratifs en s'appuyant
sur un réseau déjà existant de
commerçants plutôt que de vouloir
inventer le le bouton as un trou qui va
encore coûter très cher à leur
collectivité
alors que nous existons pour parler
aussi de l'apprentissage si je serai
très rapide pierre nous y pensons aussi
nous pensons à la relève
parce que chaque année nous avons des
mères et des pères de famille qui pousse
la porte du magasin nous demandant
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à accepter
notre gamin en apprentissage en
formation pourquoi parce que c'est à
côté
c'est dans le bourg on n'a pas à se
déplacer et puis lorsque et je rejoins
de ce que disait tout à l'heure
le directeur de la cci du lot et garonne
lorsqu'on vient dans une petite
entreprise pour apprendre le métier on
la prendrait mans c'est peut-être la
grande différence qui peut y avoir avec
des multinationales qui parfois
apprennent juste à rendre à remplir
certains rayonnages nous nous sommes
prêts nous sommes prêts à relever les
défis en 2017
nous serons prêts et nous serons force
de proposition à condition que le
prochain gouvernement prennent le temps
de nous occuper de nous écouter tant sur
la ruralité que c'est le problématique
de santé publique
merci merci pascal